well speaking of Donald Trump he did a
fox news interview with Brett Bear that
you uh saw a little bit of from producer
Pat's show yesterday and round two was
broadcasted out or something on Fox News
um and so we have more clips from that
and the moment I have for you now is so
dang
bizarre stunning humiliating for Trump
and just a moment on television you
don't see too often where Brett Bear
pose is a very good question to Trump
based on something he was bragging about
and Trump just has a complete confused
malfunction as you're about to see
before I look at that moment with you
um this is from USA
today huh Donald Trump pardon recipient
would face the death penalty under his
new
plan part of Donald Trump's record in
office freeing convicts with long prison
sentences for relatively minor drug
offenses has run up against one of his
2024 campaign planks the death penalty
for drug dealers Trump seemed rattled
this week when told that Alice Johnson a
high profile pardon recipient would be
vulnerable to execution under his new
Criminal Justice proposal huh Trump said
during an interview broadcast Tuesday
when Fox News anchor Brett Bear told him
that she'd be killed under your
plan and indeed uh confusion was gushing
out of trump in this moment after he was
told that as the article noted Alice
Johnson an individual who was a
non-violent drug offender who Trump
pardoned while he was president under
his new proposal that he's been
campaigning on of implementing the death
penalty for drug dealers
she would be someone subjected to
possibly being executed take a look as
an example
a woman who you know very well
was in jail she had 24 more years to
serve she served for 22 years she had
Thomas Johnson Alice she was in the
Super Bowl high quality oh yeah
I said how many years and she was on a
telephone call and they were involved in
selling marijuana mostly marijuana
and she got like 50 years in jail but
she'd be killed under your plan huh as a
drug dealer no no no no under my oh
under that uh it would depend on the
severity it would depend on the sad
let's just watch that little part one
more time
that's a level of panic That You Don't
See too often for many of these
individuals but uh Trump included take a
look involved in selling marijuana
mostly marijuana
and she got like 50 years in jail but
she'd be killed under your plan
huh as a drug dealer no no no under my
oh under that uh it would depend on the
severity it would depend on the sad and
she's technically a former drug dealer
she the she had multi-million dollar
cocaine ring and a drug dealer look so
even Alice Johnson in that you can't do
it okay by the way if that was there no
she wouldn't be killed it would start as
of now so you wouldn't go
as it
so this highlights a couple things the
first being
how incorrect of a policy proposal that
is but the second being and I think
we're all very aware of this even the
thing is he said he proposes and he
promotes he doesn't understand care
about or have any actual substantive
belief in based on some policy analysis
come on as if and so there he probably
never thought about the fact that on one
end he'll promote the fact that he
pardoned non-violent drug offenders such
as Alice Johnson and on the other end
he's talking about executing people just
like Alice Johnson
and that just there occurred to him
um based on Brett Bear's questioning and
you saw the confusion that came of it
but indeed he has been promoting at
rallies and
um elsewhere the idea of the death
penalty for
drug dealers
I am calling for the death penalty for
drug dealers and human traffickers which
will upon its Passage
reduce the
it will reduce drug distribution
and it once again shows us
how everything is for Applause
everything's how does this play in this
given moment over here people kind of
liked that I pardoned someone like Alice
Johnson so I'm going to talk about that
and over here people cheer when I say
death penalty for drug dealers there's
no coherence and there's no
um policy principle it's just for the
Applause
um and for Trump's ego here's another
example of this I'm calling on
Republicans and Democrats immediately to
Institute to get to Washington and
Institute the death penalty for drug
dealers you will no longer have a
problem
yeah so then when those two
Applause lines contradict we get the
moment that you just saw complete and
total
confusion and panic
when you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your
activity private internet access
protects you from the prying eyes of
hackers your internet service provider
tech companies private internet access
is also super fast for streaming and for
downloads you can watch your favorite
streaming platforms as if you're in
another country like the UK to access
cool new content and with just one
account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience 83 percent
off that's 203 a month plus four months
free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link
is down below